imagine you read one hour a
day about
history how much you will learn after
365 hours in one year think about if you
study about the history of musicians of
composers how much you would know well
it's one for the money imagine if you
would work on the business and some
business that you want to develop every
day for an hour imagine how further
along you will go we don't have the time
we have 24 hours a day we sleep 6 hours
a day so it gives you still 18 hours the
average person Works around 8 to 10
hours Let's assume it's 10 hours so if
you have 8 hours left then you travel
around an hour a day maybe 2 hours a day
so now you have still 6 hours left so
what do you do with the 6
hours what do with the 6 hours